Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters, and we're going to be talking about what a God-made love is a
definition of that and
how that person
Tains to or
Our walk with God and understanding that God Himself
Is love. So let's go through this
God is love now. We need to remember it's not something that he contains. It's not something that he
possesses. It's who he is.
That is behind everything that he has or will do. He is love.
Without a God of love
Our theology or our correctness of scriptural understanding, but all our outward acts of
Trying to be good, trying to be like Jesus. Just remain very cold and sterile
impotent to really change lives and
polluted by our own self-righteousness, our own inner sin
Without truly tasting the essence of God that is a God-made love
We may know all the scriptures and we may have
Memorized all the right verses and even we may be great at teaching and
Expounded and extracting truths and
passionately revealing knowledge of him in his ways and without
Love without a golpe. We are dead
We may have perfected our flesh as to lead millions to Christ and
Still we ourselves could be on our way to hell Paul said in Philippians chapter 1
It is true that some preach Christ some people preach Christ out of envy and rivalry
But others do so on a good will the latter do so in love
Know that I and put here for the defense of the gospel
The former preach Christ out of selfish ambition
Not sincerely, which is the great word
Agnose meaning from a purity of heart
Supposing that they can stir up trouble for me while I am in chains. He wrote this in prison
But what does it matter? The important thing is that in every way where their false motives are true
Christ is preached and because of this I rejoice
Paul is saying well at least Christ is being preached at least if the truth is being preached even at home to sinful men's hearts
It's still being preached
Our flesh is capable of some amazing things
fooling even ourselves
Paul also said that we may be capable of rightly dividing all doctrine
We may be capable of
Understanding heavenly truths of speaking with tongues of men and angels
And yet he said without love that is the Greek word agape
He said we are just a rezoning goal just a clagging irritating symbol
Without agape we really are nothing we gave nothing
We we are on our way to hell no matter how we dress it up
So what is this agape?
What kind of love is this?
Truly agape is so altogether different from what man knows to be loved that it
Would be better if it was a word that different than the word love that we say
To describe God as our English word for love is
Is really kind of an insult bordering a beating abomination?
Our English word love is used to describe our affinity towards pizza and peanut butter
I love movies and popcorn. I love old cars. I love hamburgers with Vidalia ovens on it
Well, I love God
It doesn't it doesn't quite we don't really mean that we love onions and God the same
But we really know other word we have no other way to say it without it using just different adjectives
So
What do we do in the Greek though?
That's why it said to be such a more perfect language. There's many forms of
The word love in the Greek one's love for peated butter would be the word arrows in Greek
As the Greeks Greeks would describe a lusty hunger for things
There were arrows was a perfect fit
Wisely the Greek language uses several different words
For very different kinds of love they do this for other knowns as well
Deeply
Brotherly love that we might have for another person that was held strong between friends is a
Phyllis love
I
Phyllis my wife for she is my best friend yet. I also arrows her since she is so gorgeous
But a relationship between us without a God Bay is one that could
Terribly strained and prone to crumble hence the divorce rate
Previously mentioned in in in other writings here that
Why does that take place because if my love for my wife is solely based on arrows as we age my desire for her may change
I'm not gonna look as nice. She might not desire me as well and we could just have quote unquote grown apart
Or if I only love her with a phyllis love a friendship what happens when
personalities change if I ended with a brain tumor my personality severely changes
She might not even like me anymore, but our relationship can still be held together with a God Bay
See arrows
Kind of love is really selfish
Meaning I want now for myself that which seems to be the highest and the best and the most beautiful arrows
Really is to to grasp upwards all that is great. I want that. I'm reaching beyond myself
After defining its beauty
Accepting its worthiness and judging its desirability
Oh, I decide I want it. I must have it. It's mine. I
That's an arrows love in one sense arrows is not bad
There's nothing bad about it. I'm a arrows pita butter because it's creamy sweet and buttery and full of flavor
Is it raw with that? I
judge it to be perfect on toast and spread very thick
But in a real sense
arrows is also the root of all sin I
Want the highest and the best and the most beautiful the trouble is I don't have it
You have it and therefore I want the highest and the prettiest and the sweetest thing right now the trouble is you own it
You married to her. It's not mine. Arrows is the root of lust. It's the root of sin
It's the root of desiring that which I don't possess
Arrows is also selective
Only wanting the highest and the best and the most beautiful well, you don't make my grade so you don't pass the test you are out
Arrows is truly the basis of all racism
Arrows is the base of all marital discourse. You're not performing as to my expectations
You're not worth the effort. You're not accepted. I don't love you anymore. We've grown apart
I'm going to trade you in for another one over there. That's arrows
Always making judgments
Arrows is the basis really of today's society. It's really what everything is based on
In second Timothy chapter three Paul says in the last of the last days bed will be lovers
There's that word arrows not a copy that will be arrows of themselves
News flash. He wasn't talking to or about non-christians. He was speaking to the church
He was addressing portemathy the pastor of Ephesus
Regarding a problem that he was having with a couple of unruly characters in the church Timothy my paraphrase
You think you got problems now
Well, I got news for you in the last in the last days. Um now
The church is going to be engrossed in arrows. You got a couple people swallowing up an arrows
The church is going to be engrossed with arrows. Matter of fact, it's going to be dwelling of everybody in the
congregation instead of their lives being
containers of agape overflowing onto others
It will be shallow in themselves demanding the biggest and the best and the most beautiful casting aside all
Else I we want you we need to carpet any new pews homily have not we need the best singers. We need the best presentation
It has to be a show is that what churches today
So arrows is self-absorbed
arrows is self-loving
Arrows is instead of well, how can I meet the needs of others? How can God fill me with his love so I can pour out to others
How can I be a blessing to everybody? I mean, it's well, I have this problem. I need this taken care of
Okay, I love them
With a way of to restore them to truth. No, that's not existing anymore. It's just it's it's what can I get out of this
That's not upset the ample card and lose such good givers
Maybe it's said in the church
Let's that let's just forgive and forget for we've all done the same thing before instead of how could I serve?
How am I willing to stick out my deck and be the fool if it if it will help another person
How can I stand on the truth no matter what
That's what faith is standing on the truth come hell or high waters. You're not going to be moved from this
Because that relationship with Christ is most important
It's well, how can I be minister to I don't want to lose my standing in the church over this
I don't want to be a boat rocker. So I won't question anything
This is what what the difference between arrows and agape is we become self-seekers
Self-desires instead of self-givers
So why agape? Paul Paul could have had a need of
immediate acceptance if he would have
described
The Christian faith he would have described a relationship with God as arrows
That's really what the prosperity church does today
The leaders of the early church could have had twice the converts if they just used to this word
Arrow Scott is arrows. He's the biggest and the best and the most beautiful and he wants that for you
Sadly churches today have wonderful attendance and can build phenomenal structures with coffee shops and restaurants and gourmet shops and youth centers with
falling alleys
By preaching the God of arrows
They exclaim come to Jesus and get arrows get the biggest and the best and the most beautiful because he just wants to bless
you
He'll give you everything you want
He'll supply you with all your worldly desires and he'll bless you with all the lusts your heart can imagine
Jesus may be the biggest and the best of the most beautiful, but he is not
arrows that is a lie and they pull versus out of context
Out of proper context to manipulate you and to believe in that because really that's what our heart
Is full of sin we are all sinners
And we all fall short of the glory of God. It is a really easy to appeal to that side of our flesh because we want arrows
God chose to describe himself
He did not choose to use the word arrows
Aros was not the word of his choosing God uses a new term as if it was reserved for his description at least in the Greek writing
You just don't see it elsewhere
But it was how he's in that Greek dictionary. It's like God's snuck it in there to be used
In the New Testament
From the very beginning of time that word agape very different word God is agape
Now arrows people had to think about that. Don't you mean arrows? I'm pure this conversation took place back then
Paul don't you mean arrows going to gope? What's agape?
Remember learning about that school. What is that? God does not desire the biggest and the best of the most beautiful
God does not exclude
God is that racist
God is agape
God throughout the New Testament never used our word for love
And by this I believe he's really stating
I'm not going to use your word for love
Because everything that man thinks of
And understands in the natural sense as love
Is so far removed
From who God is
When we say God is love has nothing to do with man's sloppy slurpy sweet and syrupy thing that we call love
God is agape
But remember he is agape. He doesn't contain it. He is agape
There's not something that he has. He isn't
So agape is what God is
His nature then it is safe to say that agape
Is not phoned in man
If I find agape in somebody I know I could be sure that it did not originate with them
God must have put it there
He placed it in the person's heart
It is a gift
If you see agape flowing on to me don't say oh wow not to cutters great guy
That cutters is a stinner saved by grace alone
filled with the Holy Spirit
And when I am surrendered to his spirit I can be filled with his agape
And then the fruit of the spirit can flow through me
And if that's what you see in me which I hope you do sometimes
Then rest assured the glory goes to him
John states in
First John chapter 3
Behold
What matter of love or how great a love in the word love there is agape
Behold what
Mayor of agape
The father has lavished upon us
The text literally means how strange how different this love is
He's like it's he's saying it's it's such an awesome wonder
It doesn't blow you hear out of earth
It's it's from god himself this agape
The Greek literally needs from another world
This is a different love it doesn't blow here
And I can describe it in
I can't describe it in any terms that I know of
Because people don't possess it out of their own accord
God placed it here
As arrows reaches up to the highest
Limits itself to the accepted
Comforts itself with the most beautiful the nice the right the righteous
The agape must be all together different than that
It is completely
Other than that
agape reaches out and down
Arrows remember reaches out I must have that that's better. That's beautiful arrows
Investigates you it scrutinizes you it places you under a microscope and says are you good enough?
Do you fit in are you the best in the most beautiful are you something I'd like to possess
Will you help me get higher? Can I use you as a stepping stone if so I'll let you in
agape is completely different
It reaches down and out and down to all
Don't want us excluded
agape does not reach out to all but it reaches down
It not only reaches out to all but it reaches down
Even to his enemies
It is to reverse of everything the world thinks
Surely my concept of God and from a natural perspective is that God would only want the highest of the best in the most beautiful in his fellowship
I come to see that in agape
He is agape who reaches down to the low lives
No wonder the Pharisees didn't like him. No wonder they were so upset
The wonder most Christians get upset when we reveal agape what it really is and who he really is
This man receives sinners and eats with them
To the religious person Jesus was against everything their idea of God represents
Is the best and the most beautiful and we're so holy and righteous
But God is agape
He loves all people of all races. He loves people of different religions
He loves Saddam Hussein. He loves murderers. He loves idolaters
Arrow says you're crazy
But agape continues to reach out to all and down to the very worst. Jesus said
You have heard it said or understood this far
Love your neighbor and hate your enemy, but I say or I am
Love your enemies
Pray for those who persecute you and you will be or or may reveal the fact that you all sons of the father in heaven
agape reaches out agape reaches down agape sees beyond appearances
agape sees the person behind the bitterness
Behind the selfishness behind the walls of strife sees the person behind the veil of intelligence and holiness and self-righteousness and pride and ignorance and foolishness that agape sees the preciousness of the person inside
agape doesn't see sinners but sees lost sheep sheep are valuable
We're all sinners. Yes, but most assuredly, but agape sees through the sin and the anger and rebellion
to what we can be
Arrow says emotion it operates on feeling an opinion
bad loves because an outward pressure to do so. I love arrow sleigh
Because you're nice to me. I love pizza because it tastes good. I love arrows everything because I judge it to be
lovable
That which is arrows
compels me to do so
But agape does not love because of any outside pressure to do so
You could not earn it through your beauty
agape doesn't love me more because I'm smart or
You know beautiful or the best or anything else. You cannot desire it through kindness or godliness or self-righteousness
God is agape. He doesn't love me because of who I am. He loves me because of who he is
In my flesh
I am truly confused with this
What kind of love is this? This is a mechanism to me
agape is fully expressed completely defined in Jesus Christ
I see it when I when he calls the disciples to follow him and he
picked the average Joe got the smart intelligent well-schooled
I see it as compassion over the death of his friend Lazarus even
As he full knew well that he was about to raise him from the dead in just a few minutes
But I also see it in Jesus as he drove out the merchants from the temple with an angry whip with loud words and with violent behavior
Unbecoming of a godly young man. That is agape
standing for righteousness
I hear the deepest agape passion in his very pointed
Condemned words to the Pharisees in Matthew chapter 23
How deep is one's love need to be for another human being than to tell him the truth
How deep does one's love need to be to allow those whom you most long to understand the truth
You allow them to hate you so vehemently that their plan was to to cause your death
This is agape
Willing to lay down his life for others
agape doesn't look very loving sometimes
But I look at Jesus
fully man yet fully God I see the full expression of agape love
At the cross he chooses he chooses God chooses he chose because of who he is agape
To die for his enemies those that were still his enemies us
While we were yet sinners Christ died for us. We were his enemies Christ died for us
Before the foundation of the earth was set
Before beginnings of beginnings God says I am the one who dies for his enemies
As goes our mind
John wasn't right this kind of love is completely other than me it doesn't belong here. It's from another planet
I am arrows fully and completely I work
For my own pleasures fight for my own right
That's who I am at my core I'm self-centered
I think about myself. I complained that I becker and demand that I wine
I want my way and I demand more and more and more. I am arrows
at my core
If I am to be fully redreamed and I am to be fully born again I need to be born again in agape
From atoms said I am naturally born into arrows all of us are
Reborded to self-witing cry I want my way self-centered self-grabbing that's who we are
If I should give my life to Christ and he reforms my spirit his agape fills me we are
Filled with his agape love that's where the fruit of the spirit can come out of John said dear friends
Let us love agape one another for love agape comes from God
Everyone who loves agape has been born of God and knows God
It's important to understand words are important
If we were to read that in our own flesh and a flesh
filled with arrows understanding we're reading it all wrong dear friends love arrows
One another yes, I'm gonna love those who are nice to me and kind to me and then fill my needs and and do my work and give me more things
For love comes from God. Yes, God wants to give me things and I just want stuff from him
And that's how my per life is surrounded about just asking asking asking
But when we read it in an understanding of agape
It's completely different
It's completely different if agape is in me that God puts it there
We need to ask for it if it's not have I really been born again
John continues in mercy by stating
The same thing in reverse for us so that we can fully grasp this
He says first and verse seven. Let's read that again
He says dear friends, let us love agape one another for love agape comes from God
Everyone who agape has been born of God and knows God and then he reverses it in verse eight
But whoever does not agape does not know God because God is agape
Katie be any plater
It is if John is answering the question of the day. Do you do you want to know the difference from a professing
Christian in a real Christian? We'll look at their life
It is is it a vessel of agape or is it not?
There's really no one between it doesn't mean or always going to be walking in agape
Of course we're not refreshedly human means
But it's that all we do is walk in agape and when we get bumped into we're spilling out agape
That's a good sign that we are we are we are born again
But if I meet somebody and it's just arrows arrows arrows me me me self self self
I want this to wait about me it's all about me what about me what about me
Oh my goodness gracious
That's just all arrows. I don't care what they claim. I don't care when they say they ask Jesus in their heart
And walk this island got baptized and did all these things and confess their faith and go to church seven days a week
Or it doesn't make a difference
Are you born of agape or are you still engulfed in arrows
What does your life look like
Look at Jesus. Don't ask what would Jesus do ask what did Jesus do
What did he do? He had compassion yet he
openly and strongly confronted him
He had compassion on people, but he still confronted what was wrong in people's life
Sometimes he was gentle
With the prostitute with zikias with Thomas and other times he was direct and loud
Even boisterous even so did angry and judgmental
A copy in disciplines see hybrid Hebrews 126
It calls false believers children of the devil see
John 843
It commands that we make right judgments and commands that we change
based on one's hearts intent and not on one's
Outside appearances it demands that we give our bodies as living sacrifices
Wow, that's tough
It preaches a depth of the law which no one can keep
So that we are driven to the foot of the cross in the desperate need of this love at a moment by moment basis
We cannot create us ourselves
It demands a breakage of our self-righteousness
Jesus is agape it's not man's syrupy sweet little religion
It's not human definition of love agape loves enough to confront
It cares enough to drag another one out of the fires of sin
And sees the salvation of one's neighbor a higher cause than the survival of one's own flesh
John goes on to state just exactly what agape looks
But what does agape love looks like in verses 9 and 10
This is how God showed his agape among us
He sent his one and only son into the world that we might live through him
Then he states it more clearly
This is
Love this is agape that that we loved God it didn't come from us
But that he agape us he loved us with this agape and he sent his son
To us as in a totally in sacrifice for our sins. This is who he is
It is if God replies if you want to see agape in action look at my son
He died for those who hate me go to the same
The world says you're crazy die for your enemies love those who persecute you your nuts
In and our flesh the world is right
For good to say we can't even get Christians to stop hating
Even those of their own homes look at the divorce rate in the Christian home
It's crazy. We don't need to learn to love each other
We don't have a learn to love each other problem
We have a
Need to surrender our hearts and souls to God so that we can receive his agape problem
That's all we got
This is something you can learn or we're going to take a lesson into agape loves
Why can we more agape like that's a that's a that's a really that's religion
Religion is no place in Christianity
It's the opposite of religion is is working on polishing your arrows
So you look more ugly. That's what religion is
Agape is ready to God. I can't do this in a way. I can do this. I can't freaking do this Lord. I can't do this
That's what being a Christian is. I can't learn agape
You have to receive it. It's from another world
It doesn't belong here. You can't find it anywhere. You can't learn it anywhere. It's not a lesson to be taught
It's not a thing to be grasped
It's a thing to be received
We have been
erodiously taught that agape love is unconditional
But the truth is is that agape love
X unconditionally. There's very big difference there
It unconditionally teaches the truth
The better how difficult it is to hear
We've taught it. Oh, God is loved. So he would never condemn sin
That's the most
Don't totally do not understand agape. You totally do not understand God
God loves a person in sin
He loves everyone with agape love, but he loves them enough not to leave them there
It unconditionally teaches the truth no matter how difficult it is
To hear the truth agape
unconditionally lifts up the lonely
unconditionally, it is good news to the downtrodden
Which we all are
So it's really good news to those who realize their sinners
It unconditionally disciplines
It unconditionally disciples in truth
It unconditionally comforts the weary
Is father to the fatherless brings acceptance to the alienated
brings judgment to the self-righteous
It unconditionally demands honesty, demands purity
acts justly
Judges rightly
corrects wrongs
Sees through sin to the to the lamb that's valuable within
But it unconditionally hates evil and demands purity
And sharpens our rough spots
If we're truly his
Our life is going to be painful
I hear cancer patients say God just wants to heal me that's I just felt God wants to heal me so that he can use me for something
Maybe it's God to use you right now through your pain
I should mold you and shape you to the image of his son
Hey be molded and shaped to the image of something else is that usually comfortable
Agape unconditionally accepts the repented sinner no matter how grave the sin is
It unconditionally works in ways to keep the believer
Through discipline
Through pain
Sometimes through painful circumstances
Sometimes through disease, sometimes through financial collapse
Because he loves us so much
Eternity is more important than your stupid circumstances right now
And unconditionally receives conviction from the Holy Spirit and accepts correction
And acts like the heavenly father
We all really desperately need
But sometimes don't want
Agape love is perfect
It sees us where we are and refuses to leave us there
Because it loves us so much
Unconditional and action
Get very conditional in our response to it
To allow it to work in our life
So we may give glory to the father in heaven
And be
That glory for him
That's what its purpose is
They said earlier that Agape even loves a sort of mosaic or picks a
worldly character that you think is wicked and evil
Yeah
If he or any other including us professing Christians
Fails to respond to Agape
Well, we will will filly shut out the life-changing power of salvation. That's that's our choice
Agape is conditionally unconditional
We must walk on a daily openness to the gospel with a heart of repentance
That could
That only she can give it we did ask for that the ability to do that
Right or Hebrew said
The Lord disciplines those he loves
And he punishes everyone he accepts as a as a as a son
The word discipline means to correct to disciple he teaches to bring knowledge to to bring truth to to correct air
It presupposes that point you know
Said to keep us blameless and spanky to us with consequences of disobedience
So so that we turn back to the truth that so we keep keep dependent upon him and not excusing sin under a bad-made false love doctrine
Why do I
Have to suffer a christ night selfish soul
Why should you experience a moment of joy
Truth returns the question
I'll let more and more and more my lust is never quenched
Even when condemned to hell condemned to death
In sin my soul is drenched
Why did he reach so low to scoop me from this molten clay? Why did he choose to snatch me
From the grip of Satan on that day
Well, nothing he saw had me nothing that I was
He chose because of who he is
Will be in who he was
He loved me in my filth and picked me all deformed
And while I shook my fist at him it was by a certain reward
With love that's from another world
Like never seen before a love that filters in and calms like it or war
That changes re-arracious clanses deep and opens eyes
He dragged me to his throne cut me open exposed by lies
That he gently gathered up the pieces
Broken spilled out on the ground and like a puzzle
He placed together
Every emptiness he found
He made me new and every day that I bowed out he makes me new again
For independence
On my savior is the beginning and the end
There is a way that seems right to man
But it's end is the way to death